Todd Phillips' new film Joker is no laughing
matter.
“haha.”
This dark, gritty, R-rated take on DC Comics'
infamous Clown Prince of Crime isn't premiering
until October 4th, but the film had its debut
on Saturday, August 31st at the Venice Film
Festival in Italy.
So what happened when audiences finally saw
Joaquin Phoenix portray the mentally unstable
comedian Arthur Fleck?
"Well no one's laughing now."
"You can say that again, pal."
Most critics agree: The film is pure magic.
According to Deadline,
"[Joker] was met with an eight-minute standing
ovation and shouts of 'Bravo!' at its conclusion."
Critics raced to their laptops to publish
their first impressions of the film, and most
reviewers were effusive in their praise.
Right now, the critical consensus on Rotten
Tomatoes proclaims that,
"Joker gives its infamous central character
a chillingly plausible origin story that serves
as a brilliant showcase for its star and a
dark evolution for comics-inspired cinema."
Writing for Vital Thrills, Jenna Busch applauded
Phoenix's transformative performance as Arthur
Fleck:
"The physical [movement] of the character
alone could convey what is going on with him,
even if there had been no dialogue.
[...] He's awkward and twisted (particularly
his arms and the position of his head) when
he's trying to be 'normal.'
The little dances he does as he tries to act
sexy or confident are the sort that make you
embarrassed for someone at a party.
As he becomes who he really is, the movements
are powerful."
Busch gave Joker a perfect score, adding,
"I'm struggling to find something to critique
here.
As I've spoken about the film to myself and
my colleagues, I've come up with nothing.
I'm sure I won't be the only one.
This standalone film was a brave choice by
Warner Bros., and it's very likely going to
pay off.
Again, this is a difficult film to watch,
and it's going to take time to process, but
ultimately, I think this is going to be a
definitive part of Joker canon."
Empire Online's Terri White also gave the
film a flawless score five out of five stars
writing that:
"[Joker is] a sad, chaotic, slow-burn study
of someone who isn't visible; who doesn't
even exist to the world around them."
Elsewhere in her review, she writes:
"What writer/director Todd Phillips and co-writer
Scott Silver[...] have written into life is
the Joker as a character.
What they and the film [are] interested in
is the mental, moral, emotional, physical
make-up of the man who became the Joker.
[...] Bold, devastating and utterly beautiful,
Todd Phillips and Joaquin Phoenix have not
just reimagined one of the most iconic villains
in cinema history, but reimagined the comic
book movie itself."
Time Out's Phil De Semlyen also gave Joker
five stars writing:
"This is a truly nightmarish vision of late-era
capitalism – arguably the best social horror
film since Get Out [...]."
In his review, De Semlyen also writes:
"[Phoenix] runs Heath Ledger cigarette paper-close
as the finest screen Joker."
Brandon Davis at ComicBook.com also gave the
film a perfect score five out of five stars.
He writes that Joker is quite unlike any DC
film or comic book movie that's come before
it.
In fact, he predicts the film will rake in
lots of awards, writing that:
"Phoenix's Arthur laughs his way through terrible
scenarios.
For this, the actor demands an Oscar nomination
[and] it might not be the only nod this DC
Comics movie earns.
The cinematography, score, and direction create
something unlike anything before it and it’s
terrifying, thrilling, and moving."
He also makes a point to say,
"There has never been a movie like this in
the genre.
[…] You'll need to see to believe it and,
even then, you still might not believe it."
Pete Hammond at Deadline loved the film too,
and was particularly affected by Phoenix's
work, writing that,
"[The actor gives] a performance so dazzling,
risky, and original, you might as well start
engraving his name on the Oscar right now."
He also claims,
"No joke, this is a movie [...] unlike any
other from the DC universe, and you will find
it impossible to shake off.
At least I did."
Hammond absolutely loved Phoenix's performance,
writing that:
"Heath Ledger took it in a different direction
in The Dark Knight and won a posthumous Supporting
Actor Oscar, and now Joaquin Phoenix gets
his turn as the character in the stand-alone
origin movie Joker in a bravura piece of filmmaking
that speaks to the world we are actually living
in today in ways that few movies do.
If you thought you knew Joker before this
Joker, think again."
Many reviewers said the film offers a stark
commentary on modern society.
Deadline's Pete Hammond argued that the film
will make audiences think about the role that
violence plays in our current culture.
Of course, not everyone enjoyed Joker but
negative reviews have been few and far between.
RogerEbert.com critic Glenn Kenny didn't feel
like the film offered any sort of meaningful
message, writing that:
"As social commentary, Joker is pernicious
garbage."
Kenny also claimed that,
"The final minutes, which will move any sentient
viewer to mutter 'would you just pick a g------
ending and stick to it?' are likely an indication
of what kind of mess we would have had on
our hands had Phillips been left entirely
to his own cynical incoherent devices for
the entire runtime."
Stephanie Zacharek of TIME Magazine felt similarly:
"The aggressive and possibly irresponsible
idiocy of Joker overall is [Todd Phillips']
alone to answer for.
Phillips may want us to think he's giving
us a movie all about the emptiness of our
culture, but really, he's just offering a
prime example of it.
[…] Joker is dark only in a stupidly adolescent
way, but it wants us to think it's imparting
subtle political or cultural wisdom."
She also found Phoenix's performance extremely
off-putting, writing that:
"[He's] acting so hard you can feel the desperation
throbbing in his veins.
He leaves you wanting to start him a GoFundMe,
so he won’t have to pour so much sweat into
his job again."
Well, viewers will finally get a chance to
form their own opinions when Joker hits theaters
on October 4th and we're sure the film is
going to hit hard.
"Is this a joke to you?"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.